the government is preparing a Crackdown
on the illegal sale of e-cigarettes to
under 18s but what actually are the
dangers of Vapes and how worried should
we be about their Rising use by children
well joining me now is lecturer in
respiratory science at the University of
Birmingham Dr Aaron Scott thanks so much
for joining us this morning
um feedback has become very big very
quickly what is the science telling us
about the dangers of it
all right I'm sure you've heard the line
before we don't know all of the dangers
or potential harms associated with it
what we know is the short-term harms
associated with us we know that it
negatively impacts immune cells within
your lungs so these are the cells that
are responsible for keeping you healthy
and well if you're exposed to something
potentially harmful like say a bacterial
infection these are cells that would
normally mop up that infection destroy
it and make sure that you were
maintained your health we knew that it
will negatively impact those and that
those cells are also the cells that are
responsible for things like chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease which is a
smoking related disease so we're
starting to see the same early signals
as harm as you would see in these much
more serious conditions like COPD
now the government is preparing to crack
down on the illegal sale of e-cigarettes
uh what is the difference between legal
and illegal Vapes
so in the UK we are under the tobacco
products directive it's actually in an
EU directive and it limits the total
amount of nicotine to 20 milligrams per
ml
um put that in perspective a tobacco
cigarette has between one and three
milligrams of nicotine in it so that's
still quite high in mind per one
milliliter but it does set at least a
limit
um and also regulates some other
additives that you can put into
in the United States for example they
don't have the same kind of limits so
they can go up to five percent nicotine
or 50 milligrams per mil that's
obviously a much a much higher dose and
that will serious implications on what
effects it has on those immune cells
within your Airways
um you can easily the problem is you can
easily get the different components for
an e-cigarette liquid and make it
yourself it's not that difficult you can
grow tobacco leaf very easily yourself
and make your own cigarettes but you can
with e-liquids so it makes it much more
open to the production of these illicit
e-liquids
now much like cigarettes um Vapes are
illegal for under 18s yet one in 10
school children are vaping what do you
make of that
well they've been made far too
accessible for underage
um you can walk into a pawn shop and buy
e-liquids you can walk into Sainsbury's
or any other supermarket and find them
at the end of the aisle where they can
be marketed where they come in lots of
attractive flavors you know you have all
the dessert flavors cheesecake flavors
banoffee pie flavored liquids makes it
much more attractive and also there's
the gadgetization of these devices you
know that you can
modify them in different ways or you get
disposable ones which are much more
easily hidden from parents shall we say
so it makes it very attractive and
whenever you also have the message that
they might be less harmful then it makes
it makes it an attractive option for
those who want to experiment when
they're younger
I mean if the kids weren't using Vapes
they'd be smoking so you know this
problem has has been is a decades-old
problem isn't it in my day it was
smoking behind the guy behind the bike
sheds and now it's it's vaping is this
just something to be expected
uh I don't think it I don't think it is
it's so well it's something we should
have expected but something we could
have done something about a lot earlier
so we know that nicotine is addictive we
know there's a little bit of a high
associative nicotine so we know that
anything delivers nicotine is going to
have them Associated addiction problem
an experimentation problem I know that
the government's uh latest announcements
said that these devices may contain
small amounts of nicotine
they contain as much nicotine if not
more than cigarettes so they're just as
open to that addiction and we could have
put these into plan packaging we could
have regulated them like cigarettes and
made them available for ex smokers
because these devices can be used by
smokers to quit tobacco cigarettes and
it's not perfect they should then try to
quit e-cigarettes but they can't use
them so they should be available for
those people they did not need to be so
accessible for younger people and that's
where we've made a mistake we've let
this happen we should have saw this
coming
are they as addictive as smoking
absolutely you nicotine is the addictive
agent
and when you put together all the
different flavors that are available
which you could not have
with cigarettes then you know you make
it you make a problem for yourself you
have an addictive agent which you know
is addictive
and then you put it into these
attractive attractive packaging and you
allow their advertisement on the side of
buses you'll either display in shops
this is what's going to happen we should
have regulated these like cigarettes
the measures are taken definitely
anything we can do to crack down on the
illicit Vapes is good that those
measures need to go further I know
that's there's many councils across
England that have called for the plan
packaging I know that Ash supports
stronger action which is I think the way
to go I think the government needs to go
further
okay it's been fascinating to speak to
you uh Dr Aaron Scott thank you so much
for joining us and happy Easter Happy
Easter